in many software job interviews you will
be asked to solve coding challenges
based on algorithms and data structures
one type of algorithm that can be used
to solve these challenges is the greedy
algorithm greedy algorithms are used to
solve optimization problems and they
select the best result at each iteration
in this course tanishq uses animations
and diagrams to help you understand how
to solve coding challenges using greedy
algorithms let's say that you find
yourself
on a square on a green square in a 2d
plane
there's a voice that comes from above
your objective is to maximize the goal
because the goal you can get is the gold
you keep
all right all of this is pretty weird uh
why are you on a 2d green square and
what is this voice but now the voice
continues and says that hey there are
three rules that you need to keep in
mind and if you follow these rules i'll
let you keep the gold
alright first rule you can move in any
direction up down left or right
second
once a path is taken there is no going
back
third the game ends when no more steps
can be taken
all right so now you're pretty excited
you have the rules in hand and you have
the objective of maximizing the amount
of gold coins you can get
of course you're in a 2d plane you
should get as many gold points as
possible
so
what you do is you go ahead and follow
the first rule i say that now i want to
look in all the four directions so we'll
go ahead and look in all the four
directions and we see this
we see that on the bottom square if we
reach and if we go to the bottom square
we'll get two gold coins on the left we
have one and on the right we have three
the top sell is a much more interesting
cell saying that you will get one gold
coin at this point of time you will get
one gold coin when you reach this square
and this square happens to be a dead end
marked by the bold lines
all right so now you'll ask the question
hey well since there is only
one way i can go you know once a path is
taken there is no going back
let me just go ahead and select three
you know i want to maximize the amount
of gold i can get and it looks like well
perhaps three might lead me to the
answer
so what you'll do is you'll go ahead and
select three and continue on and on your
journey and at the end you get three
plus one plus seven plus two plus five
total gold coins hey looks like a
successful run
but is it actually the most optimal well
the voice is kind of disappointed right
now so that makes sense that maybe you
have the optimal answer and you see the
rest of the grid and hey
we indeed found the optimal answer we
were able to maximize the good for this
particular grid
now obviously the voice is kind of
disappointed and
it does not like this so what it does is
takes you and throws you in another grid
now we'll do the same computation again
we'll go ahead and look in all the four
directions and we see it's a similar
kind of setup
mostly because the voice was lazy to
change these four squares
but now you'll again realize that hey
last time i selected greedily
i selected the biggest square that i got
i selected the biggest gold coin value
giving cell and i just followed the path
so let me just go ahead and do that
again let me just greedy pick the
highest value and hey maybe i get
optimal answer once again
and so you go on and on and on but hey
this time the voice was smarter
it only gave you zeros on this path
and now it pulls you back again and says
hey you know what you missed
if you went to the square at 2 if you
went bottom
then you would have gotten 2 plus 9
which is much greater than three
this is an example of the case where
thinking in a greedy approach will not
work
and so you might ask the question hey it
worked for the first one but if it is
not going to work optimally for all the
possible cases
why do we even need to think about
greedy solutions why do we need to worry
about greedy solutions at all
well there are two big reasons we should
worry about it first it is asked in
interviews and second is it general
algorithm that you should know because
here's the thing
life gets complicated
and perhaps when you explore every
single permutation combination you
realize that hey
this was too much effort and there might
be some problems where you can't even
explore every single permutation in
combination
and greedy in that case comes as a
savior
because using a gradia algorithm
guarantees that you will get a solution
it might be the optimal one it might not
be the optimal one but at least you'll
have a solution
all right so what we are going to do is
over the next 10 videos that i've made
we are going to look at 10 different
interview problems all from interview
bit and we're going to slowly build up
our intuitions on how to proceed with
greedy algorithm problems hello
everybody and welcome let's talk about
the problem bulbs on interview bit
we're given n bulbs in total which are
either on or off represented by 1 and 0
respectively
the condition mentioned in the question
says that turning on the ith bulb causes
all of the remaining bulbs on the right
hand side of it to flip
which means that all of the bulbs on the
right hand side which were one will
become zeros and vice versa
the goal of this problem is to find the
minimum number of switches to turn all
of the bulbs on
the constraints mention that the n the
number of bulbs can be between 1 and 10
to the power 5
and a of i can be 0 or 1 representing
that the bulb or the bit we are looking
at currently can either be 0 or 1.
all right let's take a test case and try
to work out a solution
in the case of one zero one this is the
test case we're gonna start off with we
will also set the initial cost to zero
we'll say that uh this cost is going to
keep a track of the number of flips or
the number of switches that we require
to convert everything to once
on the bottom right hand side is the
logic we are going to use which is
already mentioned in the question
the question says that if the bulb is on
well that's great we'll just continue on
but if the bulb is zero that is if the
current bit we are looking at is zero
then well we have to increase the cost
by one and flip everything on the right
hand side of it
all right so let's try to simulate and
see what happens
so this is the first element that we get
the first bit is one so we'll continue
on
now in this case we get the bit as zero
what does this mean
this means that we have to increase the
cost by one and we have to flip all of
the bits on the right hand side of it
including the current one so the zero
becomes one and the one on the right
hand side of it becomes a zero
pretty simple right
so now this is the area that we are
currently working with
what about this third element now
well since this is a zero we have to go
to the else condition
the else condition says that the cost
should be increased by one
for converting this zero to a one
and then we'll flip all of the bits on
the right hand side of it since there
are none we don't have to worry about it
anymore
and we have the final array as one one
one
at this point we note the cost which is
equal to two and we'll return this as
the final answer
now let's try to analyze the time and
space complexity of the solution
the space complexity is order of 1 since
we only ever store this cost variable on
the top right
however the time complexity is a bigger
issue
it's order of n square
see because for every single bit as
we're iterating over the array we'll
take order of n time
and for every single bit we might have
to do another special operation of
converting everything on the right hand
side of it to
be 0 or 1 basically flipping that around
so that's order of n time to iterate
over the bits and order of end time
again if the bit is a 0.
so that's order of n square time worst
case
now this was the naive solution and we
were able to
write down the knife solution just by
using what was given in the question
however can we optimize this
the optimization of the solution depends
on one single logic there's just one
thing that you need to know to optimize
this relation
all right let's take a bigger case and
try to work out and simulate what is
going to happen
in this case we have 0 1 0 1 1 0 1 1.
we see that the first bit is 0 so what
do we do
remember we went in the else case
we encounter a certain cost in this case
represented by the arrow
and because of this cost we were able to
convert this zero to a one and we have
to flip everything on the right hand
side of it so the one becomes zero and
the zeros become one so we have one zero
one double zero one double zero
now in this case we encounter a 0 again
well that's kind of a painful thing to
do as we already noted the time
complexity is out of n squared
so since we have the 0 let's go ahead
and convert this 0 to a 1 encounter a
cost of 1
and convert everything on the right hand
side of it
to be flipped so the ones become zeros
and the zeros become once again
now there's something going on there's
something very interesting in this slide
i want you to pause and ponder what's
going on there's one small little detail
that you have to figure out
all right
if you place both of these side by side
you'll realize that both of these 0 1 0
1 1 0 1 1 and 1 1 0 1 1 0 1 1
have this yellow part of the string
repeated
both of them have this yellow part of
the array repeated
now what does that mean
well this means that if you do two flips
represented by these two blue arrows
that we show
if you do two flips everything on the
right hand side of it becomes flipped by
once and then gets flipped again
in essence
they get reverted back to their original
states
think about this this makes sense
mathematically as well
say that we are looking at an array and
we are looking at a random bit in the
array somewhere in the middle
at this point let's say that the cost is
some cost variable that we have stored
over here represented in bread
now we'll ask the question hey is the
cost even or odd
is the number of flips we have done even
or odd
because if we have done even number of
flips the bit remains as is the bits get
reverted back to its original states so
the b becomes b it remains as is
however if the cost is ordered we have
to flip the bid that's because it has
been flipped an odd number of times so 1
becomes 0 and then becomes 1 and then
perhaps becomes 0 again
so if the cost is odd
we have to flip the bit
now then what well
if we can figure out this part well
we can just write down what we did
before if the current bit we are looking
at is one now we'll just continue else
will increase the cost by one
all right let's try to code this up
so here's the code written
and we're of course going to start off
with the cost equals to zero and we'll
return the cost at the end
now we'll see for every single bit in
the array we'll iterate over all the
bits in the rf we'll see if the cost
modulo 2 is equal to 0 that is if this
current bit has been flipped an even
number of times well b equals to b
b remains as is
else b equals to not b that is if the
bit was 1 it becomes 0 and if it was 0
it becomes 1.
and now we can
again ask the question as before we can
say that if this current flipped bit
is equal to one
then what
well just continue as is
and in the else condition we'll increase
the cost by one
and once we're done with this iteration
we finally will have the cost
so you can realize that this takes order
of n time complexity where n is the
number of bulbs
and it still takes order of one space
since we are not storing anything other
than the cost variable
all right so this is it for the solution
to the problem bulbs on interval
hello everybody and welcome by let's
talk about the problem highest product
on interview build
we are given an array of n integers and
the goal of this problem is to find the
highest product we can get by
multiplying three elements we can pick
any three elements from the array
the constraints mentioned that n the
number of elements in the array can be
between 3 and 5 times 10 to the power 5
let's take a couple of examples to
understand this better
when the input given to us is 1 comma 2
comma 3 comma 4 that is we have 4
elements in the array the output we get
is 24
and that's because we can multiply 2
times 3 times 4 and this is the highest
possible product we can get which is 24.
now when the input is 0 comma minus 1
comma 10 comma 7 comma 5
we multiply 5 7 and 10 together to get
350 which is the highest possible value
we can get and so we return 350 as the
answer
now what is one thing that is
immediately very clear from these
examples
the first thing we realize is that we
can sort the array and we can pick the
top three elements
in fact we can write this down and we'll
say that you know what one of the
observations in solving this question is
that we have to take the highest three
elements multiply them together and
return them at the end
now whenever you have these kind of
hypotheses whenever you have these ideas
it is always a good idea to test them
out
you have something in mind you have a
possible solution in mind try your best
to find a test case where this might not
work
all right we'll take a couple of more
test cases and see how this is playing
out
first we'll actually test this if this
actually works so let's say that the
case is minus five minus two one zero
zero three four five
in this case the logic works perfectly
because we take the highest three
elements three four five multiply them
together and get 60 as the answer
right so this makes sense our logic is
sort of making sense for all of these
three test cases
so we'll mark this as green and we'll
take another test cases as i mentioned
it is always a good idea to find test
cases for which for which this logic
might not work
and in this case is the test case minus
5 minus 2 minus 1 0 0 1 1 5.
again the array is sorted just for the
sake of convenience which is something
we'll also do in the chord part but if
we multiply one one and five together
which are the highest three elements we
get the answer as five
but this is incorrect
and this is because there's something
else going on
okay
now we now that we have this array what
is actually the answer
well the answer
is minus 5 times -2 times 5 giving us
50.
and this is the second observation that
we need to make
recall how when you multiply two
negative numbers it becomes a positive
number again
which means that we have two possible
cases that we have to consider
push we have to take the highest three
elements that's for sure that something
we have established is correct for some
test cases and for the remaining test
cases we have to consider the case where
there are two negative values and one
positive value as shown in the second
test case over here
now this second test case gets 50 as the
output which is indeed the correct
answer
all right uh instead of saying two
negative and one positive since we are
already sorting the array we can say
that you know what
consider the lowest two and the highest
one
so either we take the first uh the
highest three elements on the right hand
side or we take the lowest two on the
left and the highest one on the right
all right now let's actually talk about
the code for the solution
here is the code and
as i mentioned the first step is to sort
the array so a equals to sorted of a
which will return me a sorted array
and this will be sorted in ascending
order
so on the line seven i have height three
equals to a of minus one times minus two
times minus three basically saying that
we're going to pick the highest three
elements
and then this is the second case that i
mentioned we will pick the
two lowest elements which is a of 0 and
a of 1
and we multiply it with the high one so
which will multiply it with the highest
element on the right hand side of the
array
now the answer can be any of those cases
and so we'll simply return the max of
high three
and load to high one
and that is really it for the code of
the solution we can go ahead and submit
this
and this gets accepted
all right so this is it for the solution
to the problem highest product hello
everybody and welcome back let's talk
about the problem disjoint intervals
we're given a list of intervals each
represented by the start and the end
times
and the goal of this problem is to find
the length of the maximal set of
mutually disjointed intervals
what does this mean
let's take an example to understand this
better let's say that the input given to
us is 1 comma 2 2 comma 10 and 4 comma
6. so there are three intervals given to
us and we have to find a particular
permutation and combination of all of
them such that we can select
the mutually disjoint intervals and we
can create the maximal possible set of
them
the answer in this case comes out too
because we're going to select the
intervals 1 comma 2 and 4 comma 6
leaving out 2 comma 10.
this is the best possible case that we
can have
now this might look a bit bit cryptic so
let's go ahead and visualize this so
this is the visualization i've created
and uh by the way these do take a lot of
time to create so if you like this video
be sure to give it a thumbs up if you
like the effort i'm putting it
let me know in the comment section down
below anyways let's go ahead and plot
out the uh
intervals which is 1 comma 2 2 comma 10
and 4 comma 6
and now we're going to start off with
some simulation we're gonna say okay you
know what let's go ahead and select the
interval one comma two so this is what
happens when we select the interval one
comma two
and now we ask the question hey can we
select the interval two comma ten as
well
and the answer is no in this case
because in 1 comma 2 and 2 comma 10 we
can see that 2 is being repeated
so the point number 2 is going to create
an intersection between these two
intervals which we do not want
right so what we'll say instead is that
you know what
let's go ahead and skip over 2 comma 10
and let's see what will happen if we
include 4 gamma 6 and straight
so if you look at both of them these are
indeed mutually disjoint intervals and
we can get the final answer as 2 for
this particular test case
now we did leave out 2 comma 10 so let's
go ahead and see what will happen in a
case when we try to include 2 comma 10.
in the case we include 2 comma 10 we
have 1 comma 2 and 4 comma 6 both left
out
and that's because in 2 comma 10 1 comma
2 intersects in the two position and 4
comma 6 is basically embedded into 2
comma 10 so
when we select 2 comma 10 we cannot
select anything else
right so the final answers for both of
them are two and one
so in this particular test case we
explored two different possibilities and
we got the best possible answer as two
now
this what we have done here is twofold
the first thing we've done by default is
sort these index we've sorted these
intervals
now this sorting is something that we
commonly do in these kind of interval
questions so that's one thing that you
can keep in mind for later on as well
now the sorting thing is also very
important for this question and we'll
come back to it later
but now the second point is that we have
in a way made some sort of decision
right this question can be boiled down
to a dynamic programming problem in a
way because we are going to make
decisions
of whether we want to include 1 comma 2
or not whether we want to include 2
comma 10 or not or whether we want to
include 4 comma 6.
any time we are making these sort of
decisions and we want to look into the
future we want to look into the past and
we want to figure out okay what's going
on this current point of time
whenever we want to make decisions
we're always going to go for dynamic
programming so dynamic programming is
going to give you one correct solution
is one particular approach that is going
to give you a correct solution
but that might be a bit too complicated
and maybe there's something else going
on
and before jumping into any one approach
it's always a good idea to look at more
test cases and see if there is another
sneaky observation somewhere hidden
and so let's go ahead and try to find
out what's going on
so i've written another test case which
is one of the test cases mentioned in
the question itself on interview bit and
the test case is 1 comma 4 2 3 4 comma 6
and 8 comma 9 and i've plotted these out
again because there are two
possibilities that will consider
and just a quick aside there can be test
cases where there are multiple such
possibilities but i've only mentioned
two of them
for this test case just for the sake of
convenience
all right so let's go ahead and say that
i want to select the interval one comma
four i make a decision to include the
interval 1 comma 4 so the answer on the
right hand side will become 1 in this
case
now can i select 2 comma 3
i cannot because it intersects can i
select 4 comma 6 again no because 1
comma 4 and 4 comma 6 intersect at 4.
can i select 8 comma 9
yes i can so let's go ahead and include
that and increase the answer count by 1.
pretty good right
so as soon as we selected 1 comma 4 we
sort of created a chain of events that
led us to the answer to
so 1 comma 4 in a bit drove the solution
and we got the answer as 2.
now what if i don't select 1 comma 4 and
what if i select 2 comma 3 instead so in
the second possibility we are going to
first select 2 comma 3. now can i
include 1 comma 4 no because it will
intersect can i include 4 comma 6
yes i can because 2 comma 3 and 4 comma
6 do not have anything in common they do
not have any intersections
now can i go ahead and select 8 comma 9
as well
yes i can
and so in this way by selecting 2 comma
3 we were able to get a better answer of
3.
now if you also notice as i mentioned 1
comma 4 as soon as we select the
interval 1 comma 4 in the first
possibility it sort of drives the rest
of the decision making and the second
case in the second possibility as soon
as we select 2 comma 3 it drives the
rest of the decision making
now what is the difference between 1
comma 4 and 2 comma 3
maybe there's something inside of these
both intervals that can lead us to the
solution
so maybe this interval is uh
maybe 2 comma 3 gave us a better answer
because it starts later you know uh 2 is
greater than 1 so
this interval is smaller this interval
from 2 to 3 starts from 2 instead of 1
so maybe starting later is a good idea
maybe it's a good heuristic to get to a
solution
or maybe it's not
maybe it's the ending times that really
matter and because 2 comma 3 ends early
we can say that you know what all the
intervals that are going to end early
are going to give us a better answer
now at this point we can't really be
sure i mean we just got the hypotheses
now let's go ahead and test this out
we'll take the first example that we saw
the first very first example that we saw
which is 1 comma 2 2 comma 10 and 4
comma 6.
now which of them is going to hold in
this case
feel free to pause and see
whether starting earlier sorry whether
starting later or ending earlier is a
better heuristic to get to an answer
if you notice 1 comma 2 starts earlier
and 2 comma 10 starts later but
we do not select 2 comma 10
we do not select the interval which is
starting later we select the interval 1
comma 2 which is starting earlier which
means the point 1 is wrong
but what about ending early
we can see that both the intervals 1
comma 2 and 4 comma 6 are going to end
earlier than the larger interval of 2
comma 10. so it looks like the first
point starting later
is wrong and the second point ending
earlier is correct
and feel free to pause here and ponder
of like what this heuristic means
this makes a lot of sense because ending
early
gives us possibilities in the future to
work well
if an interval ends early right now
we can say that it leaves a lot more
space a lot more time for other
intervals to join in the party
but if an interval ends later on if it
and if an interval drags on for a long
time
well then it might block other intervals
to join the party which means that
ending early is a very good heuristic
for this question
in fact it is the optimal heuristic now
i've already explained the intuitions
but there's a formal proof behind
why ending early is going to give you
the optimal solution now if you're
interested in the formal proof is
mentioned on my website links down below
if you want to check it out
but anyways we'll keep this ending early
point in mind and we are going to go
ahead and implement this logic
so here's what i've done so the first
thing we'll do is sort the intervals as
i've already mentioned in the starting
sorting the intervals is always a good
idea and so we'll sort the intervals and
the key in this case is the lambda
function where we input x which is one
particular interval and we're going to
return x of 1 basically saying that sort
these intervals by their ending
positions because we want the intervals
that end early to come forward first and
we want the intervals which end later to
go towards the end
pretty simple so now what we're going to
do is we're going to go ahead and start
with the interval a of 0 we're going to
interval which started
and ended the earliest
so a of 0 is the interval we're going to
start off with we'll increase the count
and we'll set the count to 1 because
we're already going to select a of 0
and we'll also set the previous of s and
the previous of e in mind which is the
previous of start and the previous of n
this would make sense in a second
now what we'll do is we'll iterate over
the elements inside of the array we'll
iterate over the intervals giving us the
start and the end times of each interval
and now i'm going to ask one very
important question
i'm going to ask the question hey is
the start of this current interval i'm
looking at is before
the ending of the previous interval
let me say it again
does the current interval start
before the previous interval ends
that is is there a overlapping is there
an intersection between these two
intervals
because if there is an intersection if
this condition is true then go ahead and
pass do nothing in this case we don't
want to mess with the cases where there
are intersections we want to avoid them
instead
and in the else condition we're going to
go ahead and write you know what go
ahead and increase account because
clearly this current interval that we're
looking at is not intersecting with the
previous one so which means that we can
include this current one right so we're
going to go ahead and increase the count
by one
and we'll also say you know what
go ahead and set the previous of f
previous of s and the previous of e to
be s comma a
basically the previous intervals now
become the current intervals times
all right so this is it for the code of
the solution now i know this is one of
those questions where the greedy
solution ends up giving you the optimal
solution
and the proof for that is mentioned in
the written article on my website links
down below
in any case as i mentioned before these
visualizations do take a lot of time to
create so if you enjoy this video give
it a thumbs up it lets me know that
you find these visualizations helpful
and meaningful and if you want more of
this kind of content well go ahead and
hit the subscribe button i'll see you
very very soon
hello everybody and welcome back
let's talk about the problem largest
permutation
we're given an array of a random
permutation of numbers from 1 to n
that is we are given n total numbers
ranging from 1 to n both inclusive
and we are also given b which is the
number of swaps in a that we can make so
we can pick any two integers inside of
the array a and we can make a swap
between them
and we can do this kind of swap b number
of times
the goal of this problem is to find the
largest permutation possible
let's take an example to understand this
better
let's say that the input is a equals to
1 3 2 and b equals to 1.
now of 1 3 2 we can already see that you
know n equals to 3 which is there are
three total elements ranging from 1 to 3
both inclusive and b equals to 1 which
means that we can make one swap
instead of this adding we can pick any
two integers once and make a swap
between them
the biggest and the largest permutation
possible in this case is 3 1 2
and that is because we can swap one and
three giving us three one two
now you can imagine one three two as one
thirty two and three one two as three
hundred and twelve
and so the output is the largest
possible permutation we can get out
feel free to write down more examples
and try this out yourself
you won't be able to find any better
permutation than 3 1 2 when b equals to
1.
all right
now let's take a couple of more examples
and try to build our intuitions and
understanding from it
let's say that the input argument to us
is one two three four pretty simple
permutation right
and b is given as one which means that
we can make one swap in total
now let's actually write this array down
once again and now i'm going to ask you
the question
what is the number that has the biggest
bang for its spark
what is the number that can change the
most
is the number four right what is the
biggest number possible and so
if we can bring four to the front
that'll be better than bringing three to
the front or two to the front right
so what we'll do is we'll swap four and
one
and that's it and that's the answer for
this test case pretty simple right
we're basically trying to find the
numbers which have the biggest bang for
the buck
all right let's take another example and
we'll try to work out a solution again
let's say that the input is three two
four one five and b equals to three
which means that in this case we can
make total of three swaps
now how do we proceed to a solution
well what is the first thing that we
should do we wanna maximize the number
we want to make the number as big as
possible
so what we can do is
uh we look at three two four one five
and we realize that five is the biggest
number five has the biggest demand for
its buck right so we can take one b
we can take one step
and we can bring five to the front
that does mean three goes at the end but
you know what
a number starting from five is going to
be much greater than a number spreading
from three
so we'll make that swap happen
okay what's the next step then
well since we have three b's we can go
for another row and try to look at this
again now which number has the most bang
for its bug
since we already made a swap with five
five is already in the best position
possible
how about 4
now we can go to 4 and we can say that
you know what go ahead and swap 4 with
the element in its position so after 5
we want to put 4
and so this is exactly what we'll do
we'll swap out five sorry we will swap
out four bit two
all right so
now we'll do this
and how about this we have five four two
one three and now was the next element
that we can swap this is the last swap
that we can make
which element do you think will give the
most bang for its buck
five and four are already in place
and now we only have the largest element
three that is remaining which is not in
its place right
so we'll go ahead and swap two and three
and this is the solution for this test
case
now what is one thing that we observed
right away what is the one thing that we
realized and we were solving these
problems
what we realized was that we can
greedily replace
the higher elements so we can say that
you know what if 5 is not in its place
if 5 is not in the first position let's
go ahead and make that happen let's go
ahead and put 5 in the first place
and then we'll ask the question we'll
ask the same question for 4
we'll say hey is 4 in the right place is
4 in the second place in this test case
if 4 is not well go ahead and make that
happen go ahead and make that swap
and similarly for 3 and then 2 and then
1. now in case b equals 200 well we will
have reached a point where we have 54321
so that won't be very useful to us which
means that you know the scary constraint
given to us that b can be 10 to the
power 9 is not really meaningful since
the ra is only 10 to the power 6
elements
in any case this is the entire logic
that we need to solve the problem
we can greedily replace the higher
elements
so we'll make sure
the highest element n is at the first
position
then the second highest element n minus
1 is at the second position and so on
and so forth till we get to one
all right let's talk about the code
the first thing we'll do is set up a
couple of variables that we'll need for
related
now we set i equals to zero since i is a
pointer going from the start of the
array to the end of the array
we need i because
in the case of three two four one five
i wanted to look at the right hand side
column
note how five four and three are
underlined these are the elements that
have been swapped with the other
elements on the right hand side which
are 3 2 and 2 respectively
now
these elements are underlined because
you can imagine that i is going from the
start to the end
and i is trying to fix every single
number
so first we're going to fix 5 and then
we're going to fix 4 and then 3 and then
2 and so on and so forth
so
this max is going to keep a track of
of the current n right so this max
starts from n and then goes to n minus 1
and then n minus 2 and so on and so
forth as you can see here
now we also have this d which basically
tells us the positions of every single
element
so dictionary is a dictionary from the
value say from five to its current index
so in the case of three two four one
five
the value of the key five is four
that's because it's sitting at the
fourth index
similarly for the value 4 the index is 3
sorry the index is 2 and so on
now we're going to say while these two
conditions would while b exist while we
have any number of swaps left to be done
and we still haven't iterated through
the entire array so while we're still
iterating through the array and while we
have swaps remaining to be made
we'll do some computation
we'll say that first of all get me j
now what is j
j is the d of max basically j is the
location where the highest element is
sitting so in the case of 3 2
4 1 5
as i showed in the presentation
the in the first iteration j is going to
be what
j is the location of the maximum
possible value now the maximum is 5 in
our case so we're going to go ahead and
ask the question hey where is 5
and the answer we get is 4 5 is sitting
at the index fort
now we'll ask the question hey is the
current index i the same as the return
index j
that is
is 5 in its right position or not
now if it's in right's position well we
don't really need to do anything it's
already in its right position and we can
just continue on as is
however if it's not in its right
position we'll have to do
a swap
and so every time we do a swap we'll
have to reduce the b by one
and what is the swap going to be
swap is simply going to swap the i and
the j elements
right as we saw
uh when we realized that you know what 5
and 3 had to be swapped because 5 was
towards the end and 5 should be in the
start well we wanted to replace 5 with 3
and so 3 will move to the position of
pipe
now we'll say that a of i comma a of j
equals to a of j comma e of i basically
5 and 3 gets swapped
this is one more thing that we need to
do which is absolutely essential
which is to update their dictionary
values as well since both of these
numbers now are at different indices
than they were at before
we'll update the dictionary values
also towards the end of this while loop
will also say i plus equals to 1
basically now we'll increase the i
pointer by 1 and we'll reduce the max by
1 and that's because we started off with
the maximum value as n then we'll move
on to n minus 1 and then so on and so
forth
at the end after we have made all of
these swaps we would have a a that is
remaining and this a is something we'll
return at the end
all right so this is it for the code
and that is it for the solution to the
problem largest permutation
hello everybody and welcome back
let's talk about the problem meeting
rooms
we're given a list of intervals defined
by their starting and their ending times
and each of these intervals basically
represents a single meeting and now we
are given a list of meetings
the goal of this problem is to find the
least number of meeting rooms required
so that we can conduct all of the
required meetings
the constraints mention that n the
number of meetings can be between 1 and
10 to the power 5.
the constraints also mention that every
single time
can be between 1 and 10 to the power 9.
so let's take an example to understand
this better
let's say the input we get is 5 comma 10
15 comma 20 and 0 comma 30.
what it means is we have three different
meetings where the first meeting starts
from 5
and ends at 10. so basically you can
assume it starts at
time some t equals to 5 units and ends
at t equals to 10 units then there's
another meeting starting from 15 ending
at 20 and a third meeting starting from
zero ending at 30.
now the output of this problem is two
saying that there are at least two
number of rooms required to conduct all
of these meetings
and that is because we have to realize
that 0 and 30
0 comma 30 and 5 comma 10 are two
meetings which intersect right they take
place simultaneously which means that
we'll need to create two different rooms
so that both of them can happen around
the same time
similar is the case for 0 comma 30 and
15 comma 20. both of them again
intersect so we'll need at least two
rooms so that the meetings can actually
take place
all right let's go ahead and expand upon
this example and try to work out how we
actually got to a solution
and simulate what is going to happen
so now what i'm going to do is i'm going
to create these meetings so we have one
meeting from 5 to 10
we have another meeting from 15 to 20
and a third meeting from 0 to 30.
now what we can do is we can go ahead
and start scanning from the left to the
right
and so i'm going to create a pointer and
this is the yellow pointer that we are
going to see and this pointer is going
from the start to the end scanning the
meetings basically it is going to ask
the question hey how many meetings are
there currently going on
and so the current variable c u r r
will start from zero basically saying
that there are no meetings at time of
zero and as we iterate as we scan
through these times we'll go ahead and
increase the current which represents
the number of meetings going on
currently
and max is the second variable we need
to keep a track of which will tell us
how many meetings rooms do we require
and the max is going to be the answer at
the end
so the first thing we'll do is uh we
realize as soon as we hit time 0 we see
that there is one meeting that is
starting at this point of time
so we'll need to increase the current by
one
right so now we can go ahead and say
that current equals to one what is the
maximum number of rooms are required
maximum is just the maximum possible
value of current so we'll put one in
this place as well
now what do we do next
well the next thing we realize is that
from time zero including time one two
three four
we will only require one total meeting
room and so the current remains one but
as soon as we hit time equals to five
we'll need two meeting rooms
because at this point of time another
meeting starts right the meeting from
five to ten starts at this point of time
so the current increases to two which
means that there are two meetings going
on simultaneously
now what is the max going to be max is
going to reflect the changes in the
current and become two visible
all right so now from the point of time
five six seven eight nine we will have
two meetings running simultaneously
right so the current remains two and the
maximum remains two
but as soon as we hit time equals to ten
the current decreases back to one
and that's because one particular
meeting the meeting from five to ten has
ended right now which means that the
current number of meetings going on is
one that's the meeting from 0 to 30
which is still going on so we'll still
need one room to take care of now what
happens from time 10 to 11 12 13 14
will only ever require one total meeting
room but as soon as time hits 15
we'll need another meeting room to
accommodate both of these meetings
simultaneously the maximum stays the
same and the current becomes two
so then what happens when we move to the
time 20 well if current again decreases
to 1 since we only have one meeting
going on right now
and then at time equals to 30 the
current decreases to zero basically
saying that the meeting that was going
on earlier from 0 to 30 has ended
so the only thing that is remaining is
the maximum which is equal to 2 which
becomes the answer
now one thing that we have done across
this solution is that we're going over
every single time stamp so we're going
at time goes to zero we're going at time
goes to one and two then three then four
and five
right and we're going to look at every
single time stamp we're going to look at
every single time and scan across all of
these meetings to know which of them is
going on
as you can imagine that will take quite
a lot of time
in fact if we have cases like these
where we have one meeting from 0 to 10
to the power 9 which is by the way a
valid constraint
whenever we have these kind of meetings
well
as you realize 10 to the power 9 is not
a feasible way to deal with this right
if we iterate from 0 all the way up till
10 to the power 9 will already get a
time limit exceeded and that's even just
looking at one single meeting what if we
have multiple of these kind of meetings
that just means that this is not a good
way to look at it there's an
optimization that's hidden somewhere
all right so how do we think about the
problem now
well let's go back to the nicer example
and notice what you have done previously
the thing we realized previously was
that we only care about the places where
the change happens so what it means is
we are only going to focus on 0 5 10 15
20 and 30. we don't care about what
happens at time equals to 3 or time
equals to 7 or time goes to 16 or 24 or
31 or 32.
we only care about the times where
changes happen
we only care about time zero where our
meeting starts we only care about the
time five when another meeting starts at
a time 10 a meeting ends so we care only
about the points of times where the
number of meetings is going to change so
that's central observation in solving
this problem
in fact what we're going to do is we're
going to write down these formally so
we're going to say at times 5 15 and 0
we are going to require plus 1 meeting
rooms
what it means is as soon as we hit time
equals to 5 we'll need one more meeting
room
and if you look at the visualization
that makes a lot of sense right so what
you've done is we've figured out we have
picked out all of the starting indices
which are 5 15 and 0
as you can see from the array on the top
and we have all assigned them plus one
value similarly we have assigned minus
one value to 10 20 and 30 because if you
look at the array above again 10 20 and
30 are all the ending times basically
saying that at time equals to 10 i
require one less meeting room because at
time it goes to 10 one meeting has ended
right so now what we can do is we can go
ahead and write them in a better format
and we're going to create a tuple of
the time comma the change in the meeting
rooms required
now the next step we're going to do is
pretty simple once you understand what's
going on the only thing we're going to
do is we're going to sort all of these
numbers by their times
so 0 comes first then 5 10 15 20 and 30.
remember this is the way we discussed uh
in the initial example as well this is
how we are going to look at the problem
so what it means is
at time equals to zero i'm going to
require plus one meeting room so we're
gonna have this current in the max
variable as before and at time equals to
zero i need plus one meeting rooms so
the current now increases by one saying
that i need one more meeting room than
what i had previously i had zero so now
zero plus one becomes one
what is the max going to be
max is going to be the maximum value of
current we have seen so the maximum will
become one as well
this is what happens at time equals to
zero
now what happens when you move to time
equals to five
at time equals to five another meeting
starts so we increase the current by 1
and the maximum reflects the change
now what happens at time equals to 10
a meeting has ended now we don't know
which meeting has ended but one of the
meetings has ended that means the
requirement for the number of rooms has
decreased by one the current decreases
from two
as we saw here the current decreases
from two here to one here
all right make sense
and similarly so on and so forth we can
keep on going we can keep a track of the
current as how the meeting rooms
increase or decrease and change
at the end of this iteration you'll
notice that the current becomes zero
again because all of the meetings that
started
all of them have ended right now and
maximum is again the answer to this
problem
all right so pretty simple what's going
on right let's go ahead and implement
this
so this is the implementation with this
question the first thing we are going to
do is create this data array this data
list which is going to store
plus one so for every single starting
and ending element inside of this array
for every single meeting i'm going to
say you know what data dot append add
the value s comma 1 to the
data array
basically saying that at this start
point of time i require plus one meeting
rooms
the number of meeting rooms the
requirement of these meeting rooms
increases by one
at the same time i'm going to say
whenever this particular meeting ends go
ahead and decrease the requirement of
the meeting rooms
and so as i described earlier the next
step is going to be sorting all of these
values so we can iterate over them in a
meaningful way so the time is going to
increase one by one
and we're going to increase the time and
keep a track of the current as well as
the answer
so i'm going to say for underscore comma
b in data basically saying uh i don't
care about the time anymore i only care
about the change in the current so i'm
going to say for every single of these
values the current increases by the i so
if v is plus one the current increases
by one if b is minus one the current
decreases by one pretty simple
and the next step is then again the
writing answer equals to the max of
answer and the current
basically saying that keep on storing
the maximum possible value of current
that you can get
and at the end we can return this answer
so let's go ahead and go ahead and test
this out
we are going to go ahead and submit this
as well
all right cool so this gets accepted
hello everybody and welcome back let's
talk about the problem distribute candy
there are n kids standing in line each
of them having an integer rating
associated with them
we have to distribute the candies
following two rules
first each kid gets at least one candy
and second kids with the higher ratings
than their neighbors get more candies
the goal of this problem is to find the
minimum number of candies required to
satisfy both of these rules
the constraints mentioned that n the
number of children can be between 1 and
10 to the power 5.
let's take an example to understand this
better
when the input given to us is 1371 the
output is 7
and that's because the candies we can
give them are one two three and one
respectively
let's go ahead and take a look at a
visualization to help us understand
what's going on better so here what i've
done is i've plotted out all the values
so
the kid of the rating one is present at
the first index then the kid of the
rating three then seven and then one
back again
all right so since the goal of this
problem is to find the minimum number of
candies possible and we have to assign
at least one candy to each kid
let's go ahead and assign the kid with
the value of one
one single candy right so this is where
we are going to start
and now what happens to the kid with the
rating three
well since the kid with the rating three
has a higher rating than kid of the
rating one we have to give it more
candies now how many more well we can
give it three candies or five or ten or
hundred or thousand the goal of this
problem is to minimize the number of
candies we can give so what we'll do
instead is we'll just ensure that you
know what this kid is going to get two
candies which is greater than one
all right so this still satisfies the
condition mentioned in the question
all right so now we move on to the kid
with the rating of seven
the kid with the rating of seven looks
at the kid with a rating of 3 on the
left hand side and on 1 on the right
hand side
and realizes that wait a second i'm
greater than both of them
now it looks at the kid with the rating
3 and says that you know what since i'm
greater since i have a higher rating
than my neighbor i should get one more
candy than the neighbor so we'll assign
at the value three and now what about
the kid with the rating one at the
present at the very last
well we don't have to assign it any more
candies than the previous one because
this current kids rating is lesser than
its neighbors
which means that we can go ahead and
simply assign it the default value
saying that you know what since you are
at a lower value we're just going to
give you one candy
to formalize the logic we have seen up
till now we'll write it this way so
we'll say that if the rating of the
current kid is greater than that of the
previous kid then we are going to
increase the score by one and we are
going to save that score corresponding
to that kid
otherwise we'll set the score to 1 by
default all right so let's go ahead and
test this idea out on other test cases
to see if it actually holds up or not or
maybe it's just a product of this
particular test case
all right so let's take another example
this is the example we have
the kids are operating 1 7 4 3 and 1.
now as with previous case we're going to
assign this first kid the candy of 1
because that is the minimum number of
candies we can give
what about the kid with the rating of
seven
well it looks to the left of it and it
realized that hey
this kid has a candy of one and since i
am
since my rating is greater than that of
the previous one i'm gonna increase the
score by one so the previous score was 1
the current score becomes 2 and we're
going to save that
now when we move on to the kid with a
rating of 4 we'll ask the same question
hey
is this kid having a higher rating or a
lower rating than the previous one
so now we'll say that you know what
since 4 is lesser than 7 this kid's
rating is lower than the previous ones
we'll assign it the default value of 1
and we follow the similar logic for the
values for the kid of the rating 3 and
1.
all right so this is the answer we have
up till now following the logic we made
however this is incorrect
and that's because if you realize the
right most kid with the rating one
gets one candy and that's where it has
the lowest rating so we'll have to give
it one candy
but the kid who is at the second last
position with who has the rating three
should get actually two candies
and that's because in the question it's
mentioned that we're looking at the
neighbors which means that we're looking
at both the right and the left neighbors
together
now in this case the kid with the rating
3 has a higher rating than that of the
kid of the rating one on the right hand
side
right which means that it should get a
greater amount of candy
and so the answer changes
which means that we cannot simply
iterate from the left to the right
anymore and we cannot get the answer
this way because here's what the real
answer is going to look like kid with
the rating three is going to get two
candies because of the kid of the dating
one on the right hand side
similarly the kid with the rating four
is not actually going to get one candy
but is going to look at the kid on the
right hand side and say that you know
what hey this kid of rating three is
getting two candies so i should get more
right
so this kid will actually end up getting
the answer three
and similarly we'll look at the kid of
the rating salmon and now it goes ahead
and looks at both its right and left
neighbors the left neighbor says one and
the right neighbor says three and it
realizes hey wait a second i'm greater
than both of them
so what i'm going to do is i'm going to
pick the maximum of them i'm going to
say that you know what this right kid is
at a rating of 4 and it's already
getting three candies
which means that because i'm at rating 7
i'm i'm higher than the kid of the
rating four i should get more candies
so i'll go ahead and
get
four candies in total
now all of this was to demonstrate the
fact that we cannot simply iterate from
the left to the right
and as we saw in this case the change is
sort of
propagated from this one kid
on the right hand side and the change is
propagated from the right to the left
make sense this means that we cannot
simply iterate from the left to the
right and we can't do the same for the
right to the left case either
because if we just iterate from the
right to the left we will just have
inverted the problem
which means that iterating in either of
these directions is not going to be
helpful for us
we need a way out of the situation we
need a better way to assign candies to
kids
how about this
about to start from the lowest rating
kids
so in this case is the kids of the
dating one there are no other kids who
have a rating lower than one which means
that we can go ahead and assign values
of one to both of these kids
that's because there is
constraint mentioned in the question
that we have to assign at least one
candies to even the lowest possible
writing kids
so we'll go ahead and start with this
default case right this is the default
case keep this in mind as soon as we
find the default case we're going to
assign it one value
all right so now we'll go ahead and ask
the question for three now right we're
starting from the lowest rating kills
and we're trying to move up the ladder
so now we are going to look at the kid
with the rating three and we are going
to ask the same question
look at the right and look at the right
right
and we'll see if the kid if the current
kid's rating is greater than the left
kids rating then you have to give it one
more candy
and if the current kids rating is
greater than the right kids grating well
you have to give it
you have to give it one more candy than
the right kid
now in the case of the kid of the rating
three what do we do we look at the left
there is nothing we look at the right
there is one candy
now this current value is going to be
one plus one
so we'll say that the kid of the rating
three is going to get a value of two
you will understand this better as we
walk through this more so let's go ahead
and answer the question what happens to
the kid of the rating food
right
the kid of the rating four looks at the
kid on the left hand side
which is seven it's greater so we won't
touch that but on the right hand side is
a kid with a lower rating which means
that four can demand one more candy from
the kid of the rating three
right so it's gonna look at two and be
like okay give me two plus one candies
now please
so this is going to get three candies
and now we finally move on to the kid
with the highest rating rate we started
from the lowest hitting kids and we
slowly moved up the ladder and now we
are going to look at the kid with the
value of seven
and what is this kid going to do
this kid will look at the left kid gives
one candy
is going to look at the right kid has
three candies and now this kid will
realize hey you know what
i'm greater than both of these guys so
let me go ahead and get myself four
candies because that is going to satisfy
both the conditions all right so now
this should make a lot more sense
in fact let's go ahead and take one more
example which is a slight bit more
complicated example
but solving through this should get you
to the solution and if you're able to
solve this yourself then you've pretty
much done
the solution for this question all right
feel free to pause the video at this
point of time
and try this out yourself
all right cool i assume you paused and
solved now let's go ahead and start
walking through this test case so the
first thing we'll do is start from the
lowest generating kids in this case it's
two kids on either side
who have the rating one
so we'll go ahead and assign them one
value each right we're going to go and
give them one one candy because that is
the minimum possible candy we can give
like these are bad kids so we'll just
give them one candy and tell them to be
happy with it
now we'll move up the ladder we'll say
okay what about the kid of the rating
too we look at the left we look at the
right now the left kid has a candy of
one this guy is higher than that so it
needs more candies
so we'll go ahead and give it the candy
too
now we'll go ahead and look at the kids
of the rating three what do we do again
well look at the right most three value
kid right
this guy this guy is going to look at
the right kid which is lower and the
left kid which is at equal value
now since it found a kid with the rating
lower than i that is the current kids
value is greater than the right kids
value
we are going to the second if condition
and we'll say that the number of candies
we are going to have to give through
this kid is one plus the right kids
value
all right so now we'll go ahead and give
this the value of two
what about the second third kid which is
uh
present towards the middle
well we'll ask the same question hey
is this kid having a higher rating than
the kid on his left hand side no is this
kid having a higher rating and the kid
on the right hand side
well no again it is equal but it's not
greater
which means that we can go ahead and
assign it the default value of
1. we basically undercut the skill okay
that's the wrong explanation
now okay what about the kid of the
rating four
okay look on its right look on its left
left there is nothing but right you can
see that there is kid of rating one
so we are going to give it the value of
2
and then for the value of 7 we're going
to look at the left and look at the
right and what do we see there's 2
either k so just do 2 plus 1 giving us
3.
all right so this is it for the logic
it's pretty simple what we're going to
do is we're going to start from the
lowest ratings and we're going to
gradually move up the food chain we're
going to gradually move up the ladder
and look at from the worst kids to the
best kids and each time we'll go and
look at the left and the right and
assign it one more candy if needed
all right so let's go ahead and start
with the code
so n is the length of the array the
number of kids we have and data is what
is going to be the very helpful part for
us so data is just a sorted array of x
comma
basically saying that okay for this
particular kid rating this is its index
right that is all i've done so what we
are going to do is we are going to sort
all of these kids by the ratings
but since we are sorting we are going to
mess with the array structure right
we're going to mess with the indices so
we need a way to store the indices and
that is why we have this x comma i
instead of just x
all right cool so now we're going to go
ahead and assign one by default to every
single kit
that's the initial uh assumption in the
question we have to assign every single
kid at least one values
all right so we'll go ahead and assign
everyone at least one candidate and now
we're going to iterate over the data
we'll say that for every single x comma
i that is now x is not really important
for us but we'll say that for every
single i for every single index that you
get
we'll go ahead and ask two questions hey
if i greater than zero basically saying
that if there is a kid on the left hand
side of this particular kid and
this current kid's value is greater than
the left kids value well if that is the
case then go ahead and do
candies of i minus one plus one
right if there is a kid to the left of
you who is a valid kid then go ahead and
take its value and increase it by one
only if
the current reads current kids rating is
greater than the left ones
and we'll do the similar thing for the
kid on the right hand side and this is
just a simple sanity check just to
ensure that you know the element i plus
1 actually exists in the area or not
pretty simple
and towards the end what we can do is we
can simply return the sum of all the
candies
right as you saw the yellow elements are
all the candies for every single person
for every single kid and so we'll just
sum them all up together to get the
final value
all right let's go ahead and test this
out just to see if everything is working
correctly
and we'll go ahead and submit this
all right cool so this is it for the
video solution to
distribute candies on interview build
hello everybody and welcome back
let's talk about the problem seeds
there's a row of empty seeds and filled
seeds represented by a dot and an x
respectively
the goal of this problem is to find the
minimum number of moves required to make
the people sit together
the constraints mentioned that in the
total number of seats including both
empty and filled
are between 1 and 10 to the power 6.
so if we look on the right hand side the
input looks like dot dot x dot dot x dot
and the output of this question is two
now let's go ahead and take a look at a
visual explanation to understand this
better
so we have people two people sitting on
the indices two and five and the rest of
the seats are empty
now what can we do to get to a solution
well the question asks us to
group these people together
so what we can do is we can ask the
person sitting at the index 5 to move to
the index 3
that we will have grouped together all
of the people and we'll get a total cost
of 2.
why is that
that is because the person was sitting
at the index 5. so 5 minus 3 gives us 2.
basically we're looking at the absolute
difference between these two seats
alright so two is one possible answer
and this is one possible configuration
if you go back to the original now we
can ask the question hey is there any
other better thing that we can do
what if we ask the person sitting at the
index 2 to move at the index 4
well we'll get the same answer as 2
because 2 minus 4 in the absolute
difference of 2 and 4 is still 2.
and of course this condition is still
satisfied that these people are grouped
together at the end
so this is a pretty simple test case and
there's not a lot of things going on
so what we'll do is to get a better
insight into the problem to get a better
observation and analysis of the problem
let's go and take a look at a bigger
test case and i know this might look
scary but as we work through it this
will make a lot of sense all right so
the goal of this problem is to group all
of these people together
so how about this how about i go ahead
and assume that all of these people are
going to be grouped together starting
from the index zero so here's what we'll
do we'll ask the person sitting at the
index one to move to the index zero
this will get a cost of one
then we'll ask the person sitting at the
index foot to move to the index one so
that we can group them together
then we'll ask the person at seven to
move at two
and eight to move at three
in this we have grouped together all of
the people and we've gotten the answer
as 14.
however there is no guarantee that this
is in fact the optimal solution
so what can we do to find an optimal
solution
if you notice the goal of this problem
was to group together the people
in other words we're looking at a
contiguous segment of people that
start from a particular index in this
case these group of contiguous people
started from the index 0.
maybe that is not where we have to start
maybe
the best most optimal solution starts
from the index one instead
and so this is what can happen
basically we are going to recalculate
the cost of moving every single person
to their appropriate seats
right so one moves to index one four to
two seven to three and eight to four
make sense and we'll calculate the total
cost and now the minimum has decreased
the minimum has become ten
pretty cool right and now we still don't
know whether this is the optimal
solution or not so what we can do is we
can go ahead and we can go ahead and
test out the index two as well
right we are now going to start the
contiguous segment from 2
and so on and so forth we can keep on
doing we can keep on increasing the
starting position of the segment
and for every single starting position
of the segment we are going to calculate
the time taken the number of moves taken
for every single person we can sum them
all up together and we'll be able to get
to a solution
at the end of this iteration as we have
tested out every single index
whatever is the minimum we'll return it
as the answer
all right so let's go ahead and
implement this
i have implemented this in python 3 and
by the way just by the way one of the
things that you have to do for this
question is switch to python 2.7 because
there are some issues in python 3. uh i
am not sure what the exact issue is but
it looks to be an issue on the interview
bit side so we'll skip over that anyways
switch to python 2.7 if you're using
python all right so first thing we'll do
is set up a mod which is one of the
requirements of the question
and now what we'll do is we'll figure
out the indices for every single cross
so we'll iterate over all of those uh
all of those characters in a basically
iterating over all the dots in the x's
and we'll ask the question hey is the
current character you're looking at
is the current character an x
because if that is well go ahead and
save its index
so by the end of this iteration this
crosses will have
all the indices
of x's
and that's fine all right so this is the
first step now what's the next step
remember that when we were looking at
the array when we were looking at the
case like this we started off from index
0.
so let's go ahead and force everyone to
go to index 0.
what we'll do is we'll go from i
will go for i come across and enumerate
of crosses
we'll do cross minus i this is going to
save the number of moves required
assuming
starting position
starting position of the segment is zero
right so feel free to pause here and
understand what's going on we're looking
at the index of one cross and we're
going to move it to another index i
which is going to be the appropriate
index assuming that the starting
position of the segment is zero
and now we are going to go ahead and
find the number of process and we'll say
simply say this is one edge case we can
simply say that you know what
if n equals to zero if the number of
cross is zero well there are no people
and the entire row is empty just return
early and return zero
saying that we don't require any amount
of cost moving a person here from here
to there because there are no person at
all
all right cool this is a simple test
case now we'll go ahead and initialize
the answer starting from infinity
remember this is the minimum possible
answer that we want to get so i'm going
to initialize with the maximum possible
value
and now i'm going to start from all of
the segment stars in range of length of
a
basically whenever i have this kind of
so in this case we have an array of
limit tenth
i am going to assume that a starting
segment can be from anywhere between 0
and 10.
so this is what i've done i'm going to
iterate over every single possible start
of the segment
for each of these segment starts i'm
going to keep a track of the total cost
for each segment which is going to start
from 0. and now i'm going to say for
cross and crosses basically for every
single moves
required so this is the number of moves
now crosses stores the number of moves
for every single one of these crosses
figure out the difference between this
and the start of the segment so this
will give you the answer for the current
configuration
and now we'll do total plus sequence to
this value and total mod equals two so
basically uh this is like one of the
extra constraints the questions is the
value can be very large we have to
return minimum value mod
what is this i think a standard power
eight plus 3
all right anyways so this is like an
implementation level detail that's why i
did not mention in the
problem setup that i had anyways once we
have this total what we can do is simply
assign answer as the minimum value of
the answer and the total mod with the
mod
all right so as we go ahead and iterate
through the segment starting points and
as we go ahead and iterate through every
single one of these crosses
we will be able to get an answer so
let's go ahead and quickly test this out
all right looks to be correct and we can
go ahead and submit this so you can see
that this says test case easy success
but this will fail for hard test cases
and that's because of this loops over
here you see this loop takes order of n
time to run
and that's because we are iterating for
every single possible segments chart
now this takes order of n where n is the
number and is the length of the array
which is the number of seeds in the row
for every single one of those i also
have another order of an operation
inside of it
where i'm saying for every single cross
in cross is do something
and now the number of crosses in a row
can be order of n at maximum right if
you have 10 people in the row you can
also have a worst case where all of
these seeds are fit
so this will just be a lot of pain to do
and this is order of n nested inside of
another order of n
giving the total time complexity as
order of n square and you can see that
the test is hard failed because the time
limit exceeded
all right so how do we start to think
about optimizing this problem i mean
this is already a pretty complicated
problem but now we're asked to optimize
this
all right let's go ahead and take a
fresh start let's say that this is the
configuration we have this is the test
case we have
now if you look at it
can we not say that okay assume
1 4 seven and eight are people standing
on these indices right so these are all
of these people standing now let's say
that the person one is uh standing alone
four is standing alone but seven and
eight are having an interesting
conversation or maybe they're in a party
and now
they'll go ahead and invite person one
and four to join the party
now where do you think both of these
should land up like they want to all
meet up together right that's the goal
of the problem we have to group together
these people so since 7 and 8 are
already at their locations
they're going to go ahead and call 4 and
1 to come to their side
right so this is one way we can think
about it the answer is hidden in
clusters of people
right so maybe if there is a very large
cluster somewhere in the middle then
that might
attract all of these people and that
might minimize the number of moves we
take so this is just a heuristic
and whenever we have heuristics like
these whenever you have ideas of how the
solution might proceed
go ahead and do your best to disprove it
instead of proving it try to disprove it
and if you can find a test case where
you can disprove it well you can go
ahead and build your intuitions and
observations more
so let's go ahead and take a look at
another test case this is a little bit
more complicated but it'll do the job
so now
if you look at it there are like three
different total clusters of people there
are two clusters in the very beginning
two two words middle and three towards
the end right
so
what now well since we said that maybe
the biggest cluster is going to attract
the most people so let's assume that's
the case let's assume 10 and 12 do not
move but they're going to invite
everyone else
so 4 and 5 are going to move to 8 and 9.
this is going to take a cost of 4 and 4
respectively
similarly we are going to call 0 and 1
to 6 and 7 right
so this will take a cost of 6 and 6
giving us a total cost of 20.
now in this this case you can see that
all of them are grouped together neatly
towards the end of the adding and maybe
maybe that is the answer we are looking
for
right maybe 20 is the answer we're
looking for
but now if we use the brute force
solution to verify it we'll find that
the test case not actually satisfies the
condition is this one
the configuration which satisfies this
condition is this one
we have the starting segment index has
two
and you can see that the score we get as
two plus two for the first two guys zero
plus zero for the middle two guys the
middle two guys don't move and the last
three guys move and come towards this
place
now what does this hint you at it looks
like everyone has come towards the
middle of the area
right it looks like everyone has come
together with four and five although the
biggest cluster was ten eleven twelve
these four and five guys somehow
attracted everyone else
so maybe it's the point of middle which
is the more interesting observation we
can get
you know maybe we have to think about it
from a middle point of view
but now the question is how do you
exactly define a middle
at this point i want you to pause and
figure out what a measure of the middle
could be
i know all of this has been pretty weird
up till now is pretty new stuff
but feel free to pause at this point and
try to figure out a solution because if
you can do it trust me this is one of
those kind of questions for which the
solution you will never forget you will
never forget if you can figure this out
on your own
all right pause right now if you want to
try this out
all right so if you go back to school
level mathematics one of our chapters
we're taught is statistics
and when it comes to statistics there
are three different very common basic
ways of getting to know our data set
are three different measures that we use
very commonly
mean
median and mold
now mode as we already proved is not
going to give us the solution we're not
looking at the biggest cluster because
10 level 12 obviously moved towards the
middle so mode is out of the picture
what about mean and median
well let's go ahead and assume that mean
is going to give us the answer so what
we'll do is we'll take all of these
indices of the
people
sum them all up together and divide it
correctly so we'll have
a total of 43 divided by the seven
people that have there that are there
we have 43 as a total divided by seven
people that are there and so the mean
comes out to six
now what this means is the mean means
that
six is the middle point of the array
which means that since there are seven
total people
there should be three people on the
right of six and three people to the
left of six
however it looks like 6 is not the right
answer 5 is
5 is more middle than 6 somehow
so clearly mean is not the correct way
to look at it
what about median instead
if we look at median we get 0 1 4 5 10
11 12 and again the middle element in
this case is what
the middle element is 5
and 5 exactly matches with the perfect
the optimal solution it perfectly
matches with the optimal solution
and so it looks like we are looking at
median as the perfect position for these
segments
so median is going to define us the
answer so let's go ahead and write down
that instead of going for that large
order of n segment start loop what we
are going to do is we are going to do
something very very simple we are going
to say that the segment start
is nothing but the median the array now
what what area we are looking at we are
looking at the crosses array
and we'll figure out the n by two
element we're looking at the middle
element we're looking at the median
all right so that is all i've done that
is all the change i've made let's go
ahead and test this out once
and we'll go ahead and submit this
all right so this works out
anyways i know this was a little bit
complicated to figure out the median and
the mean thing
but
now that you know about the median thing
keep it in mind for future reference
because there are many other questions
especially the tricky ones like these
which require both knowledge of mean and
medium so
keep mean and median in mind test them
both out in given a test case and see
which one works out which one does not
and that'll give you a better way to
approach the problem and optimize the
solution hello everybody and welcome
back
let's talk about the problem sine minus
two holes
we're given n minus and n holes defined
by these two arrays
which contain position of each of the
mice and each of the holes respectively
and a mice takes one minute to travel
one unit left or right
the goal of this problem is to find the
minimum time after which all mice are in
holes
so basically the problem is we have to
select a mice and assign it a hole so
that it can travel from its position to
the hose position
taking the amount of time which is the
difference between them right
so i know this can sound a bit confusing
so let's go ahead and take an example to
understand this better so the first row
tells us the positions of the mice and
the second row tells us the positions of
the holes
so what we're going to do is we're going
to go ahead and plot this out just for
the sake of clarity so there's a mice
that exists at position three another
mice at position two and one more mice
at position position minus four
then we have three holes
one hole at zero one at minus two and
one at four
pretty simple right the problem setup is
pretty simple
now what's the greedy solution over here
what is something that you can do
greedily
well what you can do is assign
every single mice the corresponding hole
and what i mean by that is if you look
at the mice number minus 4 it can simply
go to the whole number minus 2
and that's because both of them occur at
the first position
right when we sort these arrays when we
sort the mice array when we sort the
whole array we can simply iterate over
them one by one so we can say that for
the first mice we're going to assign it
to the first hole
so it'll look something like this
and we'll take total of two time because
it went from minus four to minus two
similarly now we are going to look at
the second mice and assign it to the
corresponding second hole
mice moves from two to zero taking again
a time of two
and then we look at the third mice and
assign it to the third hole and so this
mice will go from three to four
now if you realize what you've done we
have assigned the mice to their
corresponding holes
why is that correct
why will that work can we prove that
this will always work
and so to prove that this will always
work what we can do is we can prove that
the mice will never cross each other
right because if they never cross each
other they will always go to their
corresponding holes
now
can we prove that the mice will never
cross each other because if we are able
to prove that then we'll be able to
prove that our greedy solution is in
fact the optimal solution
so let's go ahead and take a simpler
case where we just have two mice and two
holes correspondingly
now let's say that the
what we want to make these mice do is
cross each other right instead of
going from
left mice to the left hole and the right
mice goes to the right hole we are going
to say the right mice is going to the
left hole and the left mice is going to
go to the right one
but here's the catch
here is the most important thing which
makes the solution happen
both of these mice are identical
i know these mice don't have any
identity of their own
which means that we can look at their
paths and we can make a split in the
middle
what i mean is this
i can say that the left mice takes just
a slight bit longer out and ends up at
the left hole and the right mice ends up
taking a longer route to go to the right
hole and now what have we done we are
saying that if the mice cross each other
that is if they have if they are in this
kind of configuration
then we can always say that we can split
them out this way
and these mice will end up taking longer
times to get to their corresponding
holes
which is approved by contradiction
because we will never take these longer
routes we will always take the shorter
most optimal corresponding route
which means that the sorting approach
will indeed work and the greedy solution
is in fact the optimal solution
so let's go ahead and code this up the
code is pretty simple the first thing we
are going to do is sort both of these
arrays so we'll sort all of the mices by
their positions and sort all of the
holes
by their positions
we're also going to have an answer which
we start from 0 and now we're going to
iterate for every single mice and every
single hole in both of these arrays so
all this does is is going to give us an
iterable of the first mice and the first
show then the second mice in the second
hole third mice and the third hole and
so on and so forth so we'll be able to
iterate over these mice and the holes
effectively
and now i can simply say that the answer
is the maximum of answer
and the absolute difference between a
and b so which is the time
my stakes which is sitting at position a
to go to the hole at position b
and that is it at the end we can return
the answer so
that is really it we can go ahead and
test this out
and submit this as well
all right cool this works out so
yeah this is it for the solution to the
problem assign mice to holes hello
everybody and welcome back
let's talk about the problem majority
element
now most of the videos on youtube will
try to explain to you the boyer moore
algorithm which is from a class of
voting algorithms
however it is one of those
which you need to know beforehand to
truly understand it plus if you're given
this question in an interview there is
no way you can come up with that on your
own
however
i'm going to present another solution
i'm going to present a solution which is
super sneaky something that you can come
up with during an interview and it's not
even hard it's pretty simple and it's
right in front of our eyes all right
without talking too much let's go ahead
and get started
all right so the problem setup says that
we're given an array of integers of
length n and the majority element is
defined as the element which occurs with
greater than n by two frequency
the goal of this problem is to find the
majority element so if we look on the
right hand side we see that the input is
3 2 4 2 2.
clearly the majority element is 2
because it occurs with a frequency of 4.
and this frequency of 4 is greater than
the required frequency of n by 2 which
is 3.
all right so
how can we get started with the solution
to this problem well let's talk about
the 9 solution what is something that we
can do right away
what we can do is create a frequency
table so we can say the 3 occurs with
the frequency of 1 2 occurs with the
frequency of 4 and 4 occurs with the
frequency of 1.
nothing special right we've just created
frequencies corresponding to each
element
and now what we can do is after this
step 1 we can take the step 2 as going
over all of the keys in the dictionary
and finding out their values and if the
value is greater than the required
frequency of n by 2 well we can return
that as the answer so in this case as we
iterate over the keys we look at 3 then
we look at 2 and we realize that 2 has a
frequency of 4 which is greater than the
required frequency of n by 2 3.
so since 2 has a greater frequency we're
going to return 2 as the answer
pretty simple right nothing too special
all right so was the space time
complexity analysis
well order of n space is required for
the solution because we're going to
store a hash map or a dictionary which
can take order of end time to generate
as well
all right so we can go ahead and
actually look at the code for this which
is pretty damn simple in python so from
collections we are going to import
counter and counted enough is nothing
but is going to create us
a hash map or a frequency table
and we're going to say counter of a
first of all go ahead and create that
counter
and then
use the most common function to get the
most common
one element so basically get the highest
frequency element
and the rest is just uh syntax related
stuff and this one-liner solution will
get you the correct answer that is in
fact how i was able to solve this in
less than one minute but
the solution is not the most optimal
because we are going to take order of n
space
and the follow-up question an
interviewer can ask you is that how can
you reduce the space
is there a way to make the space order
of one
can you make the space constant
which brings me to the sneaky solution
at this point other people will go ahead
and present to you the boyer moore
algorithm however there's a better
solution that exists right in front of
our eyes
all right so let's go and take a look at
the array again this is the same area as
we've seen before
and the constraint is now written in
front of us that we have to do it in
order of one space
if you think about it we have to
compress the entire hash map we have to
create compress sort of the entire
dictionary that we created which took
order of n space earlier we have to
compress all of that into somehow this
order of one space
sounds pretty weird right
impossible in fact
here's the thing whenever you're stuck
in a dead end like this i've explained
this by the way in other solutions on my
channel as well whenever you're stuck in
these weird kind of situations where
there seems to be no other way and the
space constraint is order of one
you have to think in terms of bits go in
the binary representations okay you
don't look at the numbers now as numbers
anymore but they're binary
representations
here's what i mean
instead of looking at 3 i'm going to
look at 3 as 0 1 1 which is nothing but
the binary representation of 3. again
i'm not going to change anything i'm not
going to write extra lines of code to
convert this this is just how it is
stored in memory
so we're going to write 3 as 0 1 1 2 as
0 1 0 and 4 as 1 0
and i've written this for all of the
numbers
now what i'm going to do is something
very interesting all right something
super super sneaky i'm going to write
answer over here and we're going to
start iterating now if you realize one
thing
the majority element is the number which
exists with more than n by two frequency
right
what it also means is that its binary
representation will exist more than n by
two times
right is binary representation itself
will have a frequency of greater than n
by 2.
what i can also say is
every single one of it bits will also
have a frequency greater than n by 2
which means that if we narrow down and
if we just look at say this particular
column
we see a lot of zeros
what does this mean
this means that majority element has
zeros in this place
and that's because this column is
overwhelmingly filled with zeros there
is a majority of zero over here and
remember we're looking for the majority
element all of its bits are in majority
so what we're going to do is we're going
to iterate over all of these columns one
by one and we'll build our answer
here's what i mean so we'll look at this
column and we'll find out the majority
element which is either one or zero
right we're not worrying about any
frequency tables or hash map right now
i've just flipped the problem on its own
head and now i'm asking get me the
frequency of one and get me the
frequency of zero that's it just two
variables nothing else
so we can see that the frequency of zero
is overwhelmingly more than the
frequency of ones
in fact it is greater than n by two
this means that the answer the majority
element has a 0 in this particular
column's position
all right what about this particular
column
that's right we see that this column is
overwhelmingly filled with once which
means that the majority element has 1 in
this place so we're going to write
1 in this answer location
and then we'll iterate over to this
column again and what do we see there
are lots of zeros not many ones the
number of zeros is greater than n by two
so we'll just keep zero over here
and that is it
so at the end of the iteration we see
that the answer is zero one zero
what is the integer representation of
this binary number
that's right it's 2. we've found the
majority element
and look at what we did right
we just iterated over all of these
columns once and say if the number is
represented in 30 bits we'll just go
over this 30 times so it's like 30 times
and just the time complexity right now
all right this will make sense a bit
more uh once we look at the code but
mostly this is the logic
what we are going to do is we are going
to iterate over these columns one by one
and then for every single column we're
going to iterate over the numbers and
find whether the bit is one or zero and
we'll count the number of ones we'll
count the number of zeros and we'll be
able to guess whether the answer will
have one or zero in this place
all right let's go ahead and look at the
code
so we're going to start off with a
couple of variables n is the length of
the a which is something we're going to
require very soon then we have the
answer which is set as 0 and this is the
answer which we are going to return at
the end
right so as you remember we start the
answer from 0
all right so now what we're going to do
is we're going to iterate over the
columns one by one so we'll say for b in
range of 32 that is
for every single bit from 0 1 2 3 all
the way up to 32 go ahead and iterate
over these columns
for each of these columns i want you to
keep a track of the number of ones in a
column because the number of zeros is
simply n minus the number of ones right
so we can just keep a track of the
number of months to get to a solution
and now we'll say you know what go ahead
and iterate over all the numbers in a
this is an order of n time operation
we'll go ahead and write order of n over
here
now we'll say that you know what if
2 to the power of b this is nothing but
2 to the power of b if 2 to the power of
b and num is true
that is this entire line means what this
lines mean that the current bit b is set
in nums if the current bit b is set in
num then we can increase the number of
ones by one
and we'll say that you know what at the
end of this iteration if you find that
the number of ones is greater than n by
two that is there are overwhelmingly a
number of ones inside of this column
we'll go ahead and make this column of 1
as well so go ahead and set this bit
1 inside of the answer we can also write
this as
this or operation and we can write it as
plus it's the same either way
anyways once we're done with all of
those columns we would have built our
answer one by one and we'll have the
answer returned at the end
so we'll go ahead and test this
hang some of this
meanwhile let's talk about the
complexity analysis the space taken is
order of one since we only ever store a
couple of variables and the time
complexity is order of n times log w now
i know this log w seems a bit off since
we're just doing uh
you know 32 total uh
iterations over for the columns but we
have to put this log of w because
this 32 is not guaranteed right they can
be numbers which are huge which are not
stored in 30 or 32 bits they may take 50
bits or 100 bits or 1 000 bits whatever
that is so we'll just say log of w
as the log of the word size
so in this case integers had a size of
like 10 to the power 9 which is
approximately 2 to the power 30 so we
took 30 times n iterations
right so it's order of n times log w
again i know this is not the most
optimal the time complexity can be order
of n and space complexity can be order
of one with the boy or more algorithm
however this is an algorithm that you
can come up with even during an
interview and the thing we realized and
the central observation that helped us
solve this problem was that whenever the
space constraint is so high whenever the
space constraint is very very hard
and we are working with these integers
and there seems to be no other way out
we have to think in terms of bits
that is the central us is the central
observation in getting a solution for
this problem this will not only help you
for this problem but other problems as
well so keep this idea in mind for later
all right anyways this is it for
solution to the problem majority element
hello everybody and welcome back let's
talk about the problem gas station
all right here's the problem setup we're
given n gas stations in total which lie
along a circular route each of them has
a of i amount of gas present
and to travel from station i to station
i plus 1 there is some cost associated
with it which is given by the b of i
so one quick thing to note is that a of
i and b of five are two elements from
the arrays a and b both of the size n
all right the goal of this problem is to
find the earliest station in terms of
the indices from where we can travel
around the entire circuit so basically
you start from a particular index i
which is the lowest possible index and
that index is such that you can start
from i and you can make a journey
and go back to i
right and we have to return minus 1 if
it's not possible
let's go ahead and take a look at an
example assume this is an example given
in the question itself and the answer to
this example is the index four all right
so index four is an index from where you
can go ahead and do an entire circular
route and come back at index four let's
try to verify this and we'll work around
with the problem setup so that we
understand what's going on better
all right so when we're in the station
for when we started the station 4 we
have gas 7 and cost 1. what does that
mean
that means that at station 4 we start
from an empty tank and we go ahead and
fill in seven units of gas
right
and now cost 1 says that to travel from
station 4 to station 0 remember this is
a circular route to travel from station
4 to station 0 is going to take one unit
of cost
right so it's going to take one amount
of gas from it which means that the
current amount of gas we have still
remaining is going to be 6.
so we have we are starting from the
station port and once we reach the
station zero we still have six units of
gas remaining so when we reach the
station zero what we'll do is we'll fill
up the tank with three units of gas
again so that brings up to nine units
and then we have to spend four more
units of gas again to travel to the next
station
so we had six plus three minus four
total amount of gas now
which gives us five
right so at station zero we have five
units of gas in our tank all right what
happens when we go to station one
we'll do five plus five minus two five
is the current amount of tank we have
five is the amount of gas we get on the
next station and we have to subtract two
as the cost so five plus five minus 2
gives us 8.
similarly what happens when we go to the
station number 2
we do 8 plus 2 minus 1 giving us 9.
and then what about station 3 we do 9
plus 1 minus 9 giving us 1.
what next
well now we can go back to the station
four this is the station we started off
from and we went ahead and we did a
complete circular loop and we reached
back at the same station station four is
the lowest possible station that we
could have started from that resulted in
a circular route
so four is the final answer for this
test case now how do we think about the
solution well the brute force solution
says that for every single index you
know iterate over the array go for every
single index and for every single index
run a simulation
right so that simulation is going to
take order of end time as we just saw
and we have to do this for every single
index that means that we are looking at
a total of order of n square amount of
time
and perhaps order of one space because
we don't really store anything than a
current variable right so we need to
think about an optimization
now before we jump into the optimization
which by the way is going to be super
simple i have to mention one trick which
i learned before
this trick has helped me out a lot in
questions where there is like a circular
route or whenever we have to go in a
circular direction
and that trick is to simply take this
array and copy paste it
all right so what i've done is i've
copied the array the first part of the
area first half of the array right now
is the initial thing and the second half
is just a copy paste of it all right and
i've also mentioned the original indices
on the top of them so the index 5 is
actually the index 0.
now how does this help us
well think about it this way because we
are going on on a circular route if we
start from the index 0 we want to end at
the index 0 again
but because circular things are a bit
more complicated to take care of what we
have simply done is we have expanded
that out and so now we are going to say
when you start from index 0 go ahead and
figure out if you can end at index 5
instead
if you start from index 1 see if you can
end at index 6 because index 6 is
nothing but an index 1.
similarly if you go to index 4 we just
want to ensure that you end at index 9
because 9 acts as 4.
so all i've done is simply taken the
initial array doubled it so in a way we
have avoided the circular thingy problem
this makes the solution a lot simpler
because the only thing we have left to
do now is to iterate over that and that
is it
all right let me walk you through the
solution it'll make a lot more sense
so let's go ahead and say that uh 0 is
the starting index
0 is the station i'm going to assume
which is going to lead me to the station
number 5. all right i'm going to assume
that so let's go ahead and mark this
this is our starting index
now this is our starting index we start
off with the empty gas tank what do we
do we fill in three units of gas and the
cost is well the cost is four
which means that the current is uh minus
one well that is not so good we have
three units of gas with us and to go to
the next station we require four
which means that we don't have enough
gas to go to the next station
here's a if condition for you we'll ask
the question hey is the current lesser
than 0
because as soon as the current becomes
lesser than 0 let's go ahead and make a
full reset let's go ahead and say that
you know what this station will not work
out for us this question this station is
uh is going to give us a negative value
we don't want that
so we are going to say that if the
station is going to give you a negative
value just set the current to zero let's
just go ahead and restart everything
from scratch and so in this case i'm
going to go ahead and initialize and i'm
going to reset the start to
i plus one
so we simply move on to the index one as
the starting position as you can see by
the yellow circle moving
now at the index one now at the station
one we again ask the same questions we
start off with an empty gas tank the
current is zero as you can see from the
if condition previously
we start off with an empty gas tank now
we fill five units of gas
go to the next station we require two so
the remaining is three
pretty simple
so now we have three units of gas
remaining that is we have three extra
units of gas and now we can go to the
next station with three more units of
gas than we had previously
so three plus two now becomes five which
means that once i reach the next station
i'm going to fill in two units of gas
which brings me up to five units then
i'm going to spend one unit of gas so it
brings me down to a total of four units
of gas
all right pretty simple still greater
than zero which means that i can i still
have four units of gas surplus i have
these extra four units of gas just lying
around just in case
so now i'm going to go ahead and go to
the index
three
so as soon as i go to index three i see
that i have four units of gas i fill in
with one bringing me to a total of five
now i have five units of gas and the
cost to go to the next station is nine
which means that the current comes out
to minus four because five minus nine is
minus four
which means that this will not work out
either
we assume that the starting index of one
will work out for us but it did not work
out for us
so what we need to do is we need to go
ahead and reset the start to i plus one
right we're gonna reset everything we're
gonna say you know what screw the index
one screw the index zero both of them
that did not work out let's just go
ahead and restart all of our
computations from the index four so
we'll restart the current to zero and
set the start to i plus one so we start
off from 4
now at this point i want you to pause
the video and figure out something
missing figure out something that is
going wrong all of my explanation up
till now has been correct but there is
one assumption
that is wrong well at least that should
look wrong to you
that's the assumption over here look at
this
earlier we considered the index 0 then
we considered the index 1 as the
starting position and we jumped to index
4 directly we never even considered
2 and 3.
so now the question is well why don't we
want to consider the indexes 2 and 3
what's wrong with them why not consider
both of them
right and so this is where the
optimization comes into play this is the
most important part right we we don't
want to go back otherwise it'll just
become like we're going to start from
every single index and that'll become n
square that's pain
but because we have this logic of
starting from start equals to i plus 1
we were able to jump a couple of indices
now again this begs the question hey why
not consider two and three
here's the thing here's the very very
important things is my new detail which
matters a lot
look at the if condition on the left
hand side the condition says that if
current is less than 0 then go ahead and
make a restart
in other words i can say that car only
passes a station when the current is
greater than equals to 0.
what this also means is that
as it passes through more and more
stations it keeps on collecting more and
more fuel that is
in a one particular station it is going
to collect at least zero amounts of fuel
if not more so it might be some positive
amount of fuel it's going to accumulate
every single station it passes through
and if it does not pass through well it
goes to the if condition and gets reset
it
so now we know that car only passes when
current greater than equals to 0 and
it's going to accumulate more and more
field
which means that starting from one did
not give me an answer right starting
from one gave us a negative value of
four
but if you start from two you'll get
even a much more worse value in fact go
ahead and try this out yourself if you
start off from two you'll get gas two
cost one giving a current of one which
is already lesser than the current of
four and now you have one
of current you add it with a gas of one
and remove cost nine basically now
giving you minus seven
so if you start off from two you are
going to end up much worse
you're going to end up with the current
value of negative seven although it does
not mean anything different but it's
just extra computation
starting from one was the best possible
option because it was the earliest we
could have started
and we could have collected a lot more
fuel if we started off from one instead
of two
but hey even one did not work out so how
in the world will do work out
all right i think that's enough
explanation for why we do start equals
to i plus one
and uh so let's go ahead and do the
computation we start from the index four
we start from the station four now and
we have gas seven cost one
what does that mean we do plus 7 minus 1
giving us 6.
now we'll go on to the next index with
the
uh
capacity of well of course the tank
capacity is infinite but now we have the
current s6 and we're going to add it to
the gas and remove the cost from it so
we'll do six plus three
minus four
notice one more thing that we're doing
remember that we copy pasted the array
once right if you can see the nicest
five six seven eight are nothing but a
copy of one zero one two three 4
and of course you can compare the gas
and the cost values as well
now all the reason why we did that was
so that we could simply iterate over it
and get our life get our job done make
life easy and it is going to make our
life easy because now it's simply going
to continue with the same logic we're
still going to keep that f condition in
mind and we're going to continue forward
all right so now we are at the index 5
where the station 5 which is nothing but
the station 0
and currently we have 5 units of gas
what happens when you go to the next one
we do 5 plus 5 minus 2 giving us
8 then we do 8 plus 2 minus 1 giving us
9
then we do 9 plus 1 minus 9
giving us one
and finally we'll do one plus seven oh
wait
as soon as we go to the next station i
want you to realize something
look at that we have reached the station
number four
and look at the station that was marked
earlier the number station 4 was marked
earlier which means that we have gone
through an entire loop
again the station number looks like it's
9 but it's actually 4 behind the scenes
right so now we are again at the index 4
we are again at the station 4. what does
that mean
what does that mean what the initial
question was
the question was find the initial index
which will find the earliest index such
that you can go and loop around once
and so we have found that index and so
what we can do is we can say if i equals
to equals to start plus n n is the
length of the array which is 5 in this
case so if 9 equals to equals to 4 plus
5
go ahead and return 4
perfect right as you can recall the
earlier answer was 4 as well and the
current answer we're going to return is
also 4
pretty amazing right we did nothing
special just two if statements i promise
you that is literally it just these two
conditions and looping over all these
values that is it nothing complicated no
special proofs or mathematic or
arithmetic you need to worry about
all right let's go ahead and code this
up now so what we'll do is figure out n
which is the length of a basically
saying that these are the number of gas
stations with us
we're going to start the current and the
starting both from zero as i mentioned
we're going to assume the start as zero
this is our starting position assuming
that this start will give us the answer
at the end
we also have current which is going to
keep a track of the current value of the
gas tank
now we are going to iterate for i and g
comma c in
a star 2 b star 2 okay just a quick
aside what this means is simply that i'm
going to take this array a and i'm going
to copy paste it once again
so a is nothing but twice of a it's just
a plus a right is the same as a plus a
all right sorry
and then we do uh b plus b or b times
two same thing we'll zip both of them a
is nothing but the gas and b is nothing
but the cost and now we're going to
enumerate over that
so as i mentioned the first if condition
is saying that you know what if the
current index i
is equal to equals to star plus n
basically you have seen this station
before the station is a loop of the
previous start that you've seen if that
is the case look at the condition over
here if that is the case i've just copy
pasted it return start
again simple very very simple okay
nothing special we're doing it's just
simple stuff
all right and then we'll go to this
statement with says current plus equals
to g minus e so what it says is whatever
the previous current was now you add it
to the certain amount of value of gas
right i'm going to say uh
this is current plus g
minus e all right very simple i'm going
to take the previous value in my gas
in my gas tank add some additional gas g
and remove some cost of
moving to the next station
and then we'll move on to this if
condition over here as i already
mentioned again simple copy paste if
current is less than zero that is if we
have
not enough gas to move to the next
station well that means that we have to
reset
the current so the current becomes zero
and we have to set the start as i plus
one
basically we'll say everything including
i
and everything before i and including i
is all useless for us let's just reset
the start to i plus one
all right so if you notice we are
returning the start over here now if you
can find an answer you'll be able to
return it over here but in case you do
not find any such answer in case there
is no such possible case
where you can take an index and loop
around the circuit once and reach by the
same index
well then you unfortunately have to
return -1 saying that you know what i
reach the end of this for loop which
means that there is no way
there's any such possible index
all right and i'm speaking let me go
ahead and actually show you and test
this out
all right cool this works out and we'll
go ahead and submit this
and there we go our answer is correct
all right so this is it for the solution
to the problem gas station
these visualizations take me a lot of
time to make and if you appreciate them
if you appreciate the high quality of my
visuals explanations and the solution
let me know in the comment section down
below and give this video a thumbs up
anyways
this is it for this video solution and
as always thank you so much for watching